[Music]
foreign you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what is making headlines with the
journalist and broadcaster Jenny
cleanman and the columnist at the
article Ali Mirage they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's take a look at what is on some of
those front pages and the front page of
the Daily Mail has tonight's breaking
story from Buckingham Palace authorities
carrying out a controlled explosion
after a man through shotgun cartridges
over the palace Gates the mail tells us
the same story on the front page of the
sun they report that the man was heard
shouting I'm going to kill the king
the guardian reports that new
anti-protest laws are going to be rushed
through in time for Saturday's
coronation
the eye goes with conservative anger
following a sue Gray's refusal to take
part in the inquiry looking into her
dealings with the labor party
while the telegraph reports that the
Home Secretary is going to announce that
spies are to be brought back in to track
down text scammers
and the Metro leads with the case of the
nurse Lucy let me accused of killing
seven babies and giving evidence for the
first time in court yesterday
and a reminder by scanning the QR code
you see on your screen during the
program you'll be able to check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch along with us
now as I said tonight we're joined by
Jenny kleeman and Ali Mirage and there
they are in the big screen at Jenny Ali
good to have you both with us and Jenna
let's start off with you in the front
page of the Daily Mail that breaking
story in the past couple of hours here
um the headline there is a man held in
shotgun cartridges drama at the palace
and the papers do have a little bit of a
extra detail just take us through it
yes we had to wait for some of these
front pages to arrive today because this
of course happened at seven o'clock a
lot of the papers would have uh scrapped
their plans for a front page to put this
on it there was a controlled explosion
uh because a suspect through cartridges
shotgun cartridges it's been reported uh
over the walls into Buckingham Palace
apparently when armed Royal protection
officers apprehended him he had a knife
on him
um he we we don't know all the details
at the moment but we do know that only
one person has been held and the daily
mail and also the front of the telegraph
as well as reporting that it was a a
mental health episode that's how the
daily mail rephrases this phrases it
rather than an attempted terror attack
we also know that
um King Charles and Camilla uh were not
in Residence at the time so this is a
very worrying incident
um although it does sound like a
disturbed individual it sounds like a
lone wolf attack on the basis of what we
know but again this is very much
breaking news
it also shows that the security the
palace security is in one respect doing
its job well because they apprehended
this person they exploded his bag and
he's in custody but it's also quite
worrying this close to the coronation
that anything can be thrown into the
grounds of Buckingham Palace that
shouldn't be possible that shouldn't be
um the case and you know only in 2017
there was a man who was armed with a
sword who drove towards Buckingham
Palace who is serving time at the moment
for terrorist defenses so regardless of
what motivated this attack the fact that
anything got into the grounds of
Buckingham Palace is worrying
particularly at this time yeah thanks
for that Jenny and Ali let's just uh
let's keep moving on because as I said
the newspapers do have a bit more detail
go to the front page of the sun Jenny
mentioned the man in 2017 with the saw
let's not forget the man who climbed
across the wall in Windsor Castle with a
crossbow
um as well and Ali the front page of the
Sun Palace shotgun Terror they have and
they've got some more detail about
reporting of what this man was shouting
when arrested
yeah apparently he was shouting he
wanted to kill the king I mean we have
to wait for more details to come out I
mean the thing that is uh concerning
about this is as Jenny says we're very
close to the coronation now this is
going to happen on Saturday you've got
International dignitaries from all
around the world coming here the
spotlight of the world is going to be on
London and obviously it's a huge moment
the first time in 70 years that we're
having a coronation so this is a really
really important event for the country
and we also have to put it in context we
don't know about the actual situation
here about what the motivations of this
individual were whether he's suffering
from mental health problems or whether
there's some other motive uh to this or
other background to it but what we do
know is there have been a number of
terrorist attacks in the capital in
recent years resulting in deaths you saw
the Westminster Bridge attacks the
London Bridge attacks uh the Lee Rigby
attacks I mean there's been all sorts of
attacks that have gone on so the threat
of terrorist attacks is very real I
remember uh just before the Olympic
Games in 2012. I was actually just
behind the reform Club in palmau and
noticed a suspect package there called
the police they were there in a Flash
and also did a controlled explosion
because you don't expect to find
briefcases lying around uh the corners
behind uh clubs in palmouth and I think
similarly the police will be uh clamping
down on this very very quickly which is
why you've seen this man arrested
straight away and no one's taking any
chances which seems exactly the right
thing to do and just remember in 1982
Michael fagin did get into Buckingham
Palace and have a chat with the queen so
these kind of things have happened
before yeah they haven't did it and uh
just worth reminding everyone the police
said this is not being treated as a
terror related incident at this stage
but of course we'll get more detail um
in the coming hours as to exactly what
happened all right Jenny let's move on
to the front page of the Guardian
coronation related of course and um some
interesting reporting of the guide in
there taking it as an exclusive just
take us through this
is an exclusive
that comes from the anti -antives group
Republic feeding it to the guardian
these new anti-process powers apparently
going to be rushed through in time for
the coronation uh an official warning
letter has been sent to the group
Republic from the home office saying
that that new powers have been brought
forward to prevent disruption at Major
sporting and cultural events and you'll
think that obviously Republic will have
passed this on to the guardian in order
to Garner sympathy and say that they
should be allowed to protest as loudly
as possible in the run-up to the
coronation and they will be really
regretting having given this story to
the guardian today to run in tomorrow's
news when all the other newspapers will
be about security concerns around the
palace and around the coronation I think
a lot of people feel quite sympathetic
feel the policing of uh protests given
how febreil the situation is but
nonetheless
um we need to think very carefully about
the right to process in this country and
particularly when it comes to the
monarchy because the whole point of the
monarchy in this country is it is by
consent we have a royal family because
we allow there to be a royal family and
particularly at a time when over the
weekend uh you know the we were all
being uh that the news was was being
revealed that we're going to be asked to
pledge allegiance to the king in the
coronation something that even people
who are quite Pro the monarchy felt a
little bit uneasy about
um this doesn't sit very well this idea
that of how to speak out against the
monarchy uh might be curbed but uh yes
not a good time to be trying to make a
point about uh excessive police powers
and Crackdown on anti-monarchy
protesters when we've got security
issues in the palace that would make a
lot of people uh very much in favor of
quite a heavy police presence yeah and
Ali just a quick thought from you then
then on this um the uh the head of that
group Republic Graham Smith said it's
very odd that they got this letter at
this time
well look I I don't think that this is
an assault on freedom of civil liberties
at all I think is absolute nonsense
frankly I think the situation is and
this is not just about Republican the
monarchy here it's also about just stop
oil and animal rising and all these
other groups that go around believing
they have a right to disrupt people's
lives uh climb gantries on the M25 scale
the Dartford Crossing uh ruin the
people's lives prevent them getting from
work stop people getting from hospital
to your hospital and prevent children's
kids getting to school I think it's
extremely selfish we all understand that
people have different views in a society
that's acceptable it's a democracy of
course it is if you're anti-monarchy you
can go and peacefully protest around uh
Westminster like everyone else but these
talk these um stories we've been hearing
in the last few days about a particular
groups thinking about throwing rape
alarms at horses in the Queens in the
king's coronation parade what a
ridiculous thing would that be to do I
mean do these people actually think
about how animals react in that kind of
situation I think it's selfish I think
it's disruptive I think it's completely
counterproductive to their aims if
you're a republican that's absolutely
fine we can have a civilized debate
about it but the coronation and
disrupting it in this particular manner
is in poor taste and also is not safe
for the animals or the people involved
all right let's move on then guys and
Jenny from page of the I now a couple of
papers of course I picked up on this we
got the sugoi report into the into
sugray herself sort of today but she
refused to take part the itels as uh
take us through this yes
it's like it's groundhog day isn't it
another year of waiting for Sue gray to
speak apparently she is refusing to
cooperate with the government inquiry
into her departure from Whitehall
um this is because of concerns that uh
this investigation is politically
motivated and not made based on any
official process uh for people who
aren't complete Westminster uh uh
Watchers this is to do with Sue gray who
of course investigated partygate last
year she is now due to become Kia storm
as chief of staff there is an
investigation into whether or not that
is is proper uh the guardian has been
reporting
um that there had been widespread
widespread briefing today that this
report was going to find that she had
broken the civil service code uh by uh
by talking to labor and agreeing to take
up this position but yet ministers have
failed to publish it the conservatives
are accusing her of sabotaging her own
reputation uh by failing to cooperate
with this inquiry labor says that uh
she's speaking to the appointment's body
uh she's going around the right channels
she just doesn't want to cooperate with
the cabinet office when this is
politicized all I will say is what a
giant enormous and totally avoidable
mess this is
um it is affecting her reputation I
don't think it casts any aspersions on
her party gate report which was based on
facts I think if members of the
government haven't been having parties
they wouldn't have been been found to
have uh have done wrong in her report
but it is damaging for the civil service
at a time when the Civil Service is
under scrutiny particularly after
Dominic Robb's claims of it being
politicized
um she shows on she knows a lot of
Whitehall secrets that could be
potential useful
um to the labor party and you know kirst
armor he wanted her to be his chief of
staff so that
um he could get on with the business of
being a government in waiting and now he
he may not have her for months on end
whilst this investigation takes place in
all a big mess and it's deeply avoidable
yeah it could be much longer than that
can and you haven't got loads of time
maybe 30 seconds or so but just your
thoughts on this we've got the guardian
of God on their front page as well just
that same line that she's not going to
cooperate and I guess that for the labor
party and for Sue great I'll be hoping
that this will just sort of run out the
time run out that space that she needs
before joining the labor party
well look the Boris Johnson supporters
who are living in Cloud Cuckoo Land that
their leader at the time uh was uh above
reproach of living in a different world
I mean the reason Boris Johnson went was
Patterson parties and Pinscher because
he's utterly inept at leading and not
getting herself into scrapes the fact
that Sue gray is in this mess however I
do agree with Jenny I don't think it
reflects well and one of the seven
principles known in principles is
openness and Sue gray is meant to be a
Bastion of propriety and I think that
her refusal to answer questions about
when she started speaking to kirst armor
is not a good look for Sue gray given
the fact that she's been but basically
he's now being hoisted on this patard of
being the the ultimate proprietor of
ethics and integrity in government I
don't think it looks good no it
certainly doesn't all right